might not be what you think they are
being open to the possibility that you
may have a vulnerability you weren't
aware of being open to all kinds of
opportunities to learn more about what
it is you're doing and how you might be
able to do that better
and so that's kind of a the underlying
theme now i've always been really
interested in uh i love technology and
you know computers and stuff but i'm
also really interested in watching the
way
technology and society kind of shape
each other's evolution because you know
all of the software that exists all of
you with your phones and laptops and web
portals and all that kind of stuff that
was all written by people and when
people write software they bake all of
their own assumptions and biases and
things into the way they write code
because we write code that reflects our
own understanding of the problems in the
world around us but then within my
lifetime that technology has kind of
turned around i want actually i'm going
to start shaping the world around us you
know because we have mobile devices and
we have apps and we have netflix and we
have streaming media and so you know
entire concepts like
everyone in the office gathering around
the water cooler to talk about last
night's tv that was a thing 15 years ago
because everyone was in offices and we
all watched the same programs on the
same television at the same time that's
gone technology has got rid of the tv
and now the pandemic plus technology has
mostly got rid of the offices and so
these are the kind of changes you know
that are happening all around us
now
my first experience of information
security happened when uh i was around
about probably seven seven or eight
years old and uh i had an amstrad 6128
that looked like this when you switched
it on uh and i was writing a game
because i was convinced that i could
write better games than came with the
amstrad they were not very good games
but i was also a hubristic
eight-year-old who thought i could do
anything if i just figured out how and
that bit kind of hasn't gone away and i
was going to write a game where you have
to battle robots in space on your bmx
and uh so i got the basic manual and i
learned it and i wrote 10 print welcome
to bmx robots and then i ran it and it
went welcome to bmx processor this is so
cool i'm a programmer now and i saved
bmx robots onto a disc
and i left it on the desk and uh that
night my dad formatted all of the spare
disks and when i came back the next day
my bmx robots game was gone forever
and i got a little bit upset because i
was like but that was my work and so dad
said all right i'll tell you what i'm
gonna give you your own disc so you get
your own disc here and uh you can write
your name on it and you can store all
your games on and stuff now
i wasn't an idiot i wasn't gonna leave
that disc on the desk with all of the
other discs where it might fall into the
wrong hands right i took the disc and i
hid it in my bedroom in a drawer next to
my thundercat comics um i never finished
bmx robots it's still somewhere
somewhere on my to-do list
but that was my first experience of
information security and my infosec
security proved absolutely rock solid
because my disk never got erased again
the data on there was completely safe
hidden in a drawer in my bedroom next to
a thundercats comic so that was my first
infosec strategy
now
why do we need security you know why
does it even matter why do we worry
about this kind of stuff well there are
four reasons why security is generally
regarded by humans to be a good idea one
keep my stuff safe if i do a piece of
work and i save it i want it to still be
there tomorrow i want to be able to go
back to something you know a year or two
from now and know that it's there i want
to be able to retrieve my work and my
source code and my you know bank records
and all these kinds of stuff that
matters we want to be able to trust that
if we've invested in something or it
matters to us we can trust it to
technology and it'll still be there
later
i don't want you to share my stuff
i want my stuff to be mine and i don't
want all of you getting access to it but
also i kind of i don't want to see your
stuff either like you don't want to see
what's in my inbox and i really don't
want to see what's in some of your
inboxes i don't even want the temptation
i want to know that the technology is
not going to have you ever lived in one
of those shared houses where all the
mail just lands on the thing and then
like eight different apartments all go
through and they pick and i'm like what
a crazy system you know how is that
possibly a good way of sending things
like credit cards and passports and it
kind of works but i don't like that idea
i don't want to know about your stuff
and i certainly don't want my stuff
shared with anyone else three
we want to be able to manage resources
now that amstrad that we had in my house
it only had a certain amount of capacity
available there were 24 hours in a day
and it was a single user system and so
we had to take turns and my parents were
like you get an hour on the computer and
then you get an hour on the computer and
then no more computer time today because
you're going to have to go outside and
play otherwise you're never going to
make it in life and i'm like haha that
one didn't really work
and then finally
we want to keep records we want to know
who did what we want to understand if
something changed on the system who was
on the system when the thing changed
what happened who had access to it now
the security model that i grew up with
was a you know a disconnected computer
sat in a room in the house with a lock
on the door and it turns out that when
you have a system like that a system
with a you know all the storage is on
disks and it's not connected to any
networks infosec is basically physical
security you want to keep your stuff
safe lock the door if you can't get in
the room you can't steal any of the
information um if you don't want anyone
else to get your stuff lock the door if
they can't get in your stuff is safe
they can't get it you can't get anyone
else's stuff because they will lock
their doors as well um controlling
access to it well if you want to go on
the computer you can ask dad to unlock
the study and then you can go in and
have computer time and keeping records
well you know who's in the house i'm
assuming if you get up in the morning
and the computer has gone missing then
you're like well who was here last night
and hopefully most people can normally
answer those kinds of questions now
that computing model
is pretty much obsolete a lot of people
like me that's how we got started you
know for the first 10 15 maybe 20 years
that i was writing code the code wasn't
connected to anything the computer
didn't have a network connection and it
sat on a table in the corner of a locked
room and that was just the model but
that wasn't the first computing uh model
that we had because actually shared
computers are significantly older than
single user computers because back when
computers looked like this and they were
really expensive there was no way you
could have one just for one person you
wanted one that was a shared resource so
you know industry corporations
universities uh this thing here does
anyone uh
recognize i don't know what the
operating system that is shown in this
picture is
it's a thing called ctss it was one of
the earliest multi-user operating
systems it ran on the ibm 7084 data
processing system which had lots of
exciting tapes and came in lots of big
cabinets and it is notable in history
because it was the first computer in
history that had passwords
first computer ever where if you wanted
to use it you had to sign in by telling
it who you were and then you had to tell
the computer a secret now passwords are
older than computers
there are passwords in the bible uh the
word shibboleth actually comes from a
passage in the bible about using words
to uh verify your identity there are
passwords in shakespeare but before
computers a password was something that
i knew and you knew and a secret is
something that one person knows so
passwords were based on well i'm going
to tell all my friends the secret word
and then anyone who knows the secret
word must be my friend and uh then
someone finds out the secret word and
suddenly your army gets overrun or your
castle gets invaded or whatever but this
was the first computer system that had
passwords incorporated into it and one
of the people who had access to this was
a guy called alan share
and uh he was a postgraduate and he was
allowed four hours a week on the
computer and that was not enough for all
the important research that he had to do
and so he became the first person in
history to steal a computer password
because he had an idea there was a file
that stored all of the passwords and of
course you couldn't log in and look at
the password file because what would be
the point in that but
if you didn't have access to a terminal
you could ask the ctss to do you
printing jobs you could say please could
you print these files tonight when
everything's quiet and then you could
come in the next day and there'd be a
big stack of printouts in the hopper and
you could go through and you could put
your print out in your document and so
what alan shed did is he snuck in at a
bad 11 o'clock on a friday night and he
set up a punch card request to print the
password file and he fed it into the
hopper and he went home and he came back
early the next morning
and there it was all of the users with
all of their passwords you know what he
did next he photocopied it and gave it
to all of his friends and he said here
you go if anyone doesn't have enough
computer time you can log in as all of
these different people and you can do
all this different kind of stuff and
that you know is the first uh certainly
the first documented incident in history
of uh someone's password getting pwned
as i is that correct pronunciation scott
of someone getting pwned by a punch card
on a ctss running on an ibm 7084
terminal system now you know there was
this kind of hacker ethos back then that
uh passwords were evil because everyone
should have access to everything because
people are lovely and we should just be
able to trust them and a lot of the
early multi-user systems they had no
password at all everyone you just had a
directory with your name on it like
having no locks on your doors you trust
that people are gonna do the right thing
um a couple of them even they got so fed
up of like junior undergraduates trying
to crash the system that they're just
like yeah there's a crash command if you
want to crash the system you type crash
that's it well done congratulations
don't do it again because that was the
kind of model he just assumed trust and
benevolence on everybody and then when
we started getting you know ideas like
you know passwords and security and
files that you didn't necessarily want
other people to get access to
that created the scenario of well what
are you doing if you access a file that
isn't yours and you're not supposed to
have access to because
when that happens in the real world with
you know physical objects we have words
for it we talk about theft and stealing
now
if you steal my car i get up in the
morning i look outside and i'm like oh
my car is gone uh i know immediately
that something bad has happened now if
you steal my password
you kind of haven't really stolen it
because in the united kingdom certainly
to be convicted of theft in a court you
have to prove that somebody intended to
deprive you of something it is legally
impossible in the united kingdom to
steal a password unless you can prove
that not only did you take it but you
intended that the person who had it in
the first place couldn't use it anymore
and that's why you were doing it you
steal someone's car they don't have the
car you steal someone's tv they don't
have a tv you steal someone's possible
they still got a password it still works
they may not even know that you've got
it and you know this happens all of the
time we talk about it stealing is like i
said perhaps not quite the right word
but maybe someone gets hold of your
password and uh you don't know you don't
know for months you don't know for years
and then one day you go on to uh this
website which uh some of you may
recognize and you type in your email
address and it says
you have been pwned in 19 data breaches
and i'm like ah
all of those passwords got stolen and of
course i had no idea because they still
worked the whole time now
you know the
this kind of thing sometimes it is
genuine it's like malicious employees
who are like i hate this company i'm
going to take all the passwords i'm
going to put them on the dark web
because i just want to cause them a lot
of headaches and problems and lawsuits
and all that kind of stuff but a lot of
the time this stuff just happens by
mistake
you know what will happen is uh one day
somebody will set up elasticsearch and
then somebody will be like ah the
password the login system's a bit slow
why don't we use elasticsearch to speed
up access to customer records and
elasticsearch is running by default with
no security because it's fairly common
now when you have you know components uh
elasticsearch redis things like this
they assume that you are running them on
a network where you have perimeter
security and so they don't have kind of
username password type credentials and
then somebody one day goes in and
they're like ah okay i'm gonna disable
this firewall rule just to see if i can
figure out what's why the system doesn't
work and then the phone rings or someone
says hey you coming for lunch they
forget they leave that open and a couple
of weeks later somebody comes along and
they're like oh this is interesting
there's a port open here i can
get in here and i can i can sneak in
there and i can have a look now you have
no idea nothing has broken your
dashboard is still green your website is
still up everything is fine you have no
idea that this series of small and
relatively innocent looking decisions
has left all of your customer passwords
out there on the internet in plain text
for anyone to come along until someone
comes along and they go oh well then
maybe i'll just i'll download a copy of
this just you know just in case just in
case it's interesting and i'll email a
copy to troy hunt as well in case he
thinks it's interesting now
let's be clear just because someone has
left the door open you are still not
allowed to go into their house and copy
their stuff this is completely illegal
and you should not do it and if you get
caught and convicted you will find
yourself in a great deal of difficulty
but this kind of stuff happens you know
there are companies out there who are
there like i said there are malicious
actors there are negligent actors um if
you find
that your credentials are on a website
that has got a vulnerability in it
there's often not a huge amount you can
do you know you can report it to them
now scott what generally happens when
you go to a company and you say i have
found a security problem with your
website like out of 10 how many times do
they threaten to sue you because they
suck
yeah
so 70 of the time if you say to someone
hey there's a vulnerability they will
try and make out like this is your fault
and you're a dirty criminal for having
the audacity to point out that they've
left the front door hanging off their
house um sometimes they will actually
respond responsibly and there will be a
breach disclosure and they will close
the thing sometimes it just goes on to a
to-do list there is one cis admin who is
this close from a nervous breakdown and
they've been there for three months and
the fact that redis is listening on an
open port on the internet just goes on
the massive pile of things that this
person knows are broken and it will
never get fixed in this lifetime or the
next and you're like but you've got my
password in there so really there is
only well there's three things you can
do one is don't use the internet uh
because it's a hive of scum and villainy
and it's full of criminals trying to
steal things um the kind of we i think
we missed the window on that one a
little bit um one is you have to use
passwords that you can remember and my
memory is not that good i sometimes have
to look up my own address when i'm on
the way home or you use a password
manager now i have uh
497 different accounts in my password
manager right now because every single
person on the world is like please
register i want to go on an airplane
please email address and password um i
want to buy a fridge give me an email
address and password and you know all
these sites and you know if you're using
a password manager great give me 64
characters of what do you mean my
password is too long what do you mean
i'm only allowed eight characters on the
password and it's not allowed to contain
spaces and now that's if any of you have
a site out there by the way which is
doing this uh you should feel bad
because you shouldn't even know what the
password is you should hash it and throw
it away um and we're going to see in a
second why that's important but people
who don't use password managers and who
can't remember 497 64 character random
alphanumeric codes that they haven't
used since they last flew with icelandic
airways in 2017
they use the same password for
everything because they think of a
really secure one that no one's ever
gonna guess
and this can be bad
this is aaron barr
and uh aaron used to be the ceo of a
company called hb gary federal
hb gary is a security company and still
is a security company hb gary federal
was a security company that was a kind
of spin-off that they did so they could
set up contracts doing security reviews
for governments and you know federal
services and those kinds of things and
in 2011 aaron barr thought that he had
identified some of the people behind the
um anonymous uh i'm not quite sure
everyone like the newspapers always call
them the anonymous hacker collective i
don't really like the pejorative use of
the word hacker so the anonymous you
know computer activist cyber criminal
you know them these people the ones with
the with the fifa vendetta masks and all
that kind of stuff
and uh aaron barr thought he knew who
was behind anonymous and he said he was
going to publish this there's gonna be a
big coup for his security company we're
gonna reveal the identities of the
people who are running anonymous now
one of the golden rules about internet
security is uh there's a kind of great
quote that says who are you actually
worried about getting attacked by and
you know there's three scenarios there's
russian botnets there's your angry
ex-partner and there's mossad and
russian botnets they are gonna try for
about 15 milliseconds to use the
password they found on the pirate bay
and if it doesn't work they're just
going to move on to the next one so if
you pick a long password that's going to
be fine your angry ex-partner they know
your date of birth they know your
mother's maiden name they know the
street where they know all this kind of
stuff um if you piss them off enough you
are going to have a big problem and
mossad are already in all your systems
so just live your life and don't worry
about it
but
don't make it personal do not stick your
head above the parapet and go hey
anonymous
check it out i know where you live
this is what happened next
first of all hb gary federal had a
website that ran on a content management
system now there's lots of content
measurement systems there's magento and
there's wordpress and there's drupal and
all these different umbraco kind of
systems
for whatever reason they didn't use any
of those content management systems
they hired a company to build one for
them and that company did not do a
terribly good job on it now most content
management systems you go on there and
you say uh you know mysite.com give me
page one and it goes hey here's page one
and you go give me page 24 and it says
hey page24 and you go on there and you
say hey give me page all of the users in
your database and any system built by
you know a reputable developer who knows
what they're doing will say you can't do
that that's not allowed
the people who built hb gary federal cms
hey give me page one select start from
users comma minus minus and it went oh
yeah here's a page one with every single
person in our website
so that was step one the attackers the
anonymous attackers they now had access
to the password file that was used on
this content management system now this
is just one tiny little piece of the
whole thing what happened next is they
took a look at this and they're like
okay we've got usernames and we've got
passwords and those passwords are hashed
now hashing is you take a piece of text
and you turn it into a hash
and you take another piece of text you
turn that into a hash so the piece of
text is quite short the hash is
generally pretty long the point is you
can't do this backwards if you have the
hash
it is almost impossible to turn that
back
into the original password you can't do
it now
take a look at this list of password
hashes here if you look at this very
very closely
you might notice that bob and eric's
passwords
bob and gary's passwords here the hash
on those is the same
now again if developers know what they
are doing this should never happen
because even if two users have the same
exact password you are going to generate
a random number and stick it on the end
of the password before you hash it so
that you will not even if the passwords
are the same the hashes that come at the
other side will be different do you
think the people who built hp gary
federal's content management system did
this
no they did not salt the passwords so
those passwords were hashed using it was
an md5 which is a relatively kind of
naive and uh not easy to reverse but
it's popular enough that there are
attack techniques that you can direct at
this thing
and one of them is you go online and
you're like uh i would like please a
file that contains
every single
up to about 10 characters that exists in
the english alphabet with random
combinations of numbers along with all
of their md5 hashes please this is
called a rainbow table
and what you can do is you can grab
these these go up to about 10 12
gigabytes in size so we're talking about
a fairly chunky piece of data but we're
also talking about something you can fit
in memory on a laptop that you can buy
at the airport you know we're not
talking about supercomputer type
technology here
and so what the attackers did is they
got hold of a rainbow table they ran the
hb gary federal cms through that and
they went oh look this matches
let's see if uh gary's password here is
uh for the sake of this talk
monkey123 and it worked and then they
went right we know his email address and
his password uh let's see if that works
anywhere else and that my friends is
where the whole thing becomes
spectacularly unstuck because the ceo of
the security company was using the same
email and password for twitter yahoo
gmail facebook world of warcraft world
of tanks all these different things
and
his account was a domain administrator
on the corporate g suite that ran the
entire company
so by cracking the content management
system written by the people who don't
know what they were doing because they
didn't hash any passwords they got a
password that was being reused that got
them admin access to the entire
company's email system now at that point
this is pretty much game over they
effectively have uh you're not rooters
roots is like if you're on a linux or a
unix system and you have root it means
you control everything you can delete
any file you can
upload download read write modify any
file you have total control of that
system at this point the attackers have
total control
of hb gary federal their content
management system the service they run
it and the mailbox and they're in there
and uh they're biting that time this is
the weekend before the super bowl
happens and they're like we're gonna get
as much stuff as we can and then when
the super bowl starts while that game is
on we are going to destroy this company
we are going to burn them to the ground
and they're looking around going well
what else can we do and they discovered
that there was another site site called
rootkit.com rootkit.org sorry and
rootkit is run by was run by a guy
called greg hoglund
now greg was and is a very respected
security researcher he's done a lot of
work around a rootkit is basically
something you install on someone's
computer if you want to take it over and
compromise it and all kinds of things
and he ran this research site about you
know gathering information about these
now the only thing as far as i can work
out that greg hoglund did wrong is he
had an email account on this system like
he didn't have any weak passwords or
anything it's just that he had an email
account on the hb gary federal system
that the attackers now had control of so
they went in uh they did a bit of
digging this is one of his books by the
way which is uh which is great and so
they go and they do it again they're
like okay so we now have control of the
email system we can send email that
looks like it came from these people
let's talk about email for a second
now uh i have about that many emails in
my inbox unread at any given point and
i've just learned to accept that because
they come in faster than i can delete
them but we have all most of us got
pretty good at looking at email and very
very quickly deciding is this worth my
attention or not uh you know there's the
email which is obviously legitimate
because it's a reply in a conversation
it's entirely kind of keeping within
character for what you're doing uh
actually i got an email from uh jacob
bradford from ndc on sunday night at 10
o'clock with a webex link for the
workshops and uh any of you talked to me
over the last you will know that i'm not
a huge fan of running workshops over
webex and i'm very excited to be back
doing things in person so i get this
email from him with a webex link i
assume it's a joke like i know it's from
him but i don't believe that this thing
is like this has got to be a windup it
turns out no it's actually real and we
had to set up because we had some people
who couldn't make it here in person but
when you look at an email like okay is
this really from who i think it's from
is it really about what it claims to be
about is there really a prince in
nigeria who has 100 million us dollars
that they need to get rid of and for
some reason i'm the only person that
they can come up with and you know how
do we decide say you get an email that
looks like this and it's uh hello i'm
sorry for contacting you like this i
work for amnesty international um we've
learned your son is being held prisoner
by armed militia in denmark
we've made contact with their leader and
arranged for him to be released if we
can pay the euro the ransom of 10 000
euros please contact us to arrange
payment to ensure his safe release now
from the top how far down this do you
get before you realize that this is not
real
because i'm like uh all right
i'm sorry for
well you got amnesty international
wonder are you so if you but i'm like i
work for amnesty international okay
we've learned that your son no i don't
have kids so i'm like at that point this
is not real some people do have kids
it's like your son is being held
prisoner by armed militia in denmark
does that happen in denmark
like i don't think it does we made
contact with it but let's change a
couple of details let's say so a couple
years back my brother was he spent a
year in uh south africa working on a
bush lodge he had no mobile phone
reception he's working out in the middle
of nowhere so let's say that they said
all right we've learned that your
brother is being held prisoner by armed
militia in zimbabwe and i'm like all
right well
that's not entirely i mean it's unlikely
but it's not entirely impossible and i
look a bit closer i'm like well amnesty
international one that still doesn't
look legit and i'm not gonna gamble 10
000 euros on this but say the person
behind this had managed to get into
amnesty's email relay and so it was
actually from amnesty international it
looked like a legitimate email and they
only wanted 500 bucks
at that point i'd probably be like you
know what i'm going to send them 500
bucks because i don't want to take the
risk that this is genuine and i ignored
it and this
my friends is the art of social
engineering it is breaking into people's
houses by persuading them to give you
the keys
anonymous are inside hb gary federal's
email system and
they discover that they can send email
to other people they also discover that
a uh a guy called a yusi yakuhano who's
a security researcher works for nokia he
has root access to the box that hosts
rootkit.org so they send an email to uc
that just says hey
this is from greg hogland at hp gary
federal i'm in europe i need to ssh into
the server can you open up the firewall
and allow ssh through port 59022
in that mailbox they also found an old
root password so they send this is our
password still jabberwocky or did we
change it to 8 8 screamer 88 thanks now
uc gets this email it looks legit it's
from an address he recognizes from a
person he knows he's like hey do you
have public ip or should i just drop the
firewall and it's wacky but root remote
access is not allowed no i don't have
public ip with me i'm ready for a small
meeting and i'm in a rush just reset my
password change me one two three give me
public ip and i'll ssh in and reset my
password okay
it should now accept from anywhere to 47
152. i'm testing it your password has
changed me i'm online hey in europe but
you're not in finland reply comes back
no no i'll squeeze out some time maybe
we can catch up in germany for a bit are
you sure the ip is still this
does it work now yes did you reset the
user greg no no your account is named
hoglund
okay thanks i'll email you in a few boom
game over
somebody out there has just been
persuaded to help out their friend who
is in a rush getting ready for a meeting
and in so doing they have given away the
username the password they've opened it
up they've dropped the firewall and they
have allowed this complete stranger to
ssh in because they have no idea it's a
complete stranger now
the people behind this attack they were
caught and most of them ended up going
to jail and the irony is that all of
this stuff about you know identity and
trust and breaking things mostly they
were caught because one of them flipped
and started informing the fbi about who
or the rest of them were so this whole
thing based on exploiting other people's
naivety and trust in social engineering
actually the thing that screwed most of
them is that they trusted somebody who
turned out to be working with the feds
the whole time but
they wiped out hb gary federal by the
time the super bowl monday when they uh
kicked off that game they're like right
delete that take all the email back up
the whole thing and put an archive of
their entire email system on the pirate
bay so that anyone who wants to can
download it and then we are just going
to delete every single piece of data
from all their systems rootkit.org just
went it vanished that night and it never
ever came back it's been offline ever
since now like i said the the people
behind it they were eventually they were
caught they were arrested they did time
but if you look at the escalation of
that
every step there is a you know when you
think about a computer security and
attacks a lot of the time the mainstream
media portrays it as these kind of you
know the genius hacker in the hoodie and
stuff but it's not every step of this
attack was just as sophisticated as it
needed to be to get to the next step sql
injection that's not difficult you can
get tools that will do this
weak hashing well that's the next step
all right we got passwords ah rainbow
tables we'll decrypt those now we have
plain text passwords ah they're being
reused on a bunch of other stuff social
engineering and boom end of story whole
system is now over and been completely
wiped out now
to me these kind of attacks they fall
into three different categories first of
all there's what i call the technical
exploits this is the attacker versus the
system there's no other people involved
it's just them looking for
vulnerabilities buffer overflows buffer
under runs you know open ports things
been left open even the kind of you know
smash your way and through a window in
the middle of the night and find a
network port and leave something on
there that's going to give you access to
the building from outside but
there's no kind of other people involved
the second category
is the things people do when they think
nobody is watching
this is the people who i mean you know
you should use different passwords
you're the ceo of a security company but
your passwords are secret so how's
anyone ever gonna know if you use the
same one on all these different systems
and you know this is a kind of oh well
you really really shouldn't install
games on your work laptop but they're
not going to find out i'll get rid of it
before i go back into the office and man
it's these kind of behavior it's the
things that people do that they kind of
they know they're wrong but they think
they're not going to get caught and
besides it's probably not that big a
deal and you know one of the the great
headaches in security is giving someone
a laptop or access to a computer system
that does not give them the access they
need to be able to do that job
um you know i used to work in media i
spent a long time working for a company
who ran a set of video studios in soho
in london and we had video hardware in
there that would only work if you had
admin access to the workstation it was
installed on and so you know we had uh
freelance camera operators coming in and
it's like oh yeah well we actually need
to give you admin access to this
computer just so you can do the job we
hired you to do um if you say to
somebody uh we need you to edit this
report and you're like but i only have
the report as a pdf you know and like
well i don't have a pdf editor that
person is going to find a website where
they can turn a pdf into a word document
so they can edit it because nobody in
history the bosses said have you got
that press release ready and they said
oh no boss it was not possible to do it
in compliance with our corporate
security policy so i didn't do it
because that doesn't happen in real life
because bosses do not do stuff like that
in real life and then the third category
of vulnerabilities
is the social engineering it's
engineering relationships of trust
between individuals in a way that causes
somebody to give away something that
they shouldn't have done now you think
about that the hv gary attack there what
do you think you see is thinking he's
sat there at his laptop and uh you know
he's not paranoid about this he's
thinking hey my friend greg is in
trouble i got a chance here to be the
hero and you know that is a powerful
tendency most people or certainly many
people they want to help they want to
help someone out we all know what it's
like to be stuck in a tight spot and no
one is helping you you can't get into
the system or you need to get that file
that you forgot to take with you we can
relate to that situation and so we know
what it feels like and so when we think
someone else is there our instinct is we
can we can help them out here
and that
is how we're going to steal a bunch of
money
so uh this is in attack and uh this is
the cto of initech this is alice and
this is bob and bob works in finance and
we are going to wait we have got access
to their email server because we found
the passwords for somebody and we asked
god no one knows this yet we've been in
there for a couple of weeks just kind of
waiting and watching how things unfold
they don't know we're in there we are
gonna wait we are gonna wait until about
5 30 on a friday afternoon because we
know that every friday alice goes to her
zumba class and she puts her phone in a
locker and for a couple of hours she'll
be doing zumba with her friends and then
they'll go out to a bar afterwards but
for that couple of hours she is
unreachable she's not gonna be checking
her phone and at that point we send this
email to bob and we say hey it's from
alice
bob i need a favor metacortex have
agreed to 25 off hosting for the next
year but only if we get it signed off
today everyone else has already left and
their payment system doesn't work with
amex so i can't use my card can you wire
eight thousand five hundred and fifty
dollars to this account asap so we can
get it signed off now you're bob first
thing you probably do is you pick up the
phone can't get hold of alice phone's
off um you know maybe she's at zuma
maybe she's on an airplane maybe she's
just switched her phone off she's
unreachable she's in meetings but we
know she's unreachable so we know bob
can't verify this now maybe bob is like
well this is a corporate email from the
cto i'd probably better do what they
asked me to do maybe bob says hey is
this legit and gets back i'm at the
airport and can't get any phone
reception just make the transfer they
said if they don't get cleared funds by
7 pm the deal's off it's already 6 35.
what do you do
are you going to be the one who goes nah
screw the deal
you know i only work in finance i don't
trust the cto they're probably lying i
don't care how hard they worked on this
or do you transfer eight and a half
thousand dollars to this account because
you've got it in writing from the cto
with confirmation following up so you do
it this is real this is called a friday
afternoon attack friday afternoon fraud
and it is absolutely endemic it'll be
one person who's left in the office and
somebody has got access to uh either
like you know they've spoofed uh cloned
a mobile phone or they've got access to
the email they've got some way of
getting hold of this person and making
it look like they are the cto or the ceo
or someone like that
it's friday afternoon because no one's
going to notice for the entire weekend
and probably no one's going to notice
until a couple of weeks later when they
realized that this transaction went
through at hapa 6 on a friday night
bob's the only person left in the office
or you know bob's the only person who's
still working everyone else has already
left by the time they figure it out the
money has bounced through half a dozen
accounts it's completely gone you have
no idea when that money is definitely
not going to be coming back anytime soon
and you know it all boils down to how do
we make a decision
about who should we trust when we
interact with other people people we
know people we just met people we're
talking to an email or on zoom we bring
a whole bunch of our own kind of social
uh you know cultural uh prejudices and
assumptions and things and to play with
it you know um you meet someone for the
first time you make a snap judgment who
is this person are they legit are they a
threat to me is this someone i could be
friends with do business with have a
relationship with uh you know this
person would you trust them what about
this guy
what them you know
and all of these things come into play
how many of these people would you
immediately assume a trustworthy and
what does that say about you and what
does that say about them and what does
it say about the way the relationship
between people who look like these
people and people who look like the rest
of us is portrayed in media and in the
societies that we grow up in and stuff
and one of the big challenges that we
are having again and again now is that
it's not even enough to decide whether a
human being is trustworthy or not it's
proving a problem deciding whether a
human being is a human being or not
now
when you try and sign up for anything
online you will almost invariably have
to prove that you're a real person
because it is so easy for things that
are not real people to just go and
register a couple of hundred thousand
accounts overnight and then use them to
do nefarious and mischievous things now
i have no idea how to tell whether
someone clicking links on my website is
a real person or not um
and so what we tend to do is we
outsource it we say well if we can solve
a captcha then uh and very few people
run their own capture so like we'll put
a google capture on the page and so
they'll do that now when you do that
you're also training you know google
engines to drive around and find traffic
lights so it's kind of an interesting
way of donating your intelligence and
intellect to a company with a hundred
bajillion dollars
or maybe we're like well if they got a
mobile phone they must be a real person
because bots don't have phones or if
they got a credit card and all we're
doing is we're kind of you know pushing
the things back we're like well we can't
be bothered to check but presumably if
they have a credit card the bank checked
and so we're going to say well if it's
good enough for the bank it's good
enough for you and if they got a mobile
phone presumably the phone company
checked and if it's good enough for the
phone company it's good enough for us
and if neither of those then maybe
google checked and if it's good enough
for google um and if you don't have any
of these things then you're basically
stuck because you are not allowed to
cooperate and play online
now
this is not you know you probably have a
picture on your head right now you know
somebody with bees in their beard living
in a cave in wisconsin with a load of
canned food
that's not the only scenario we're
talking about there was an article in
nbc earlier this year about a company in
chicago who
they rehabilitate prisoners who have
just been released now i want you to
imagine you've been in jail since 1983
you have never seen a mobile phone you
have never seen an internet connection
you have no idea what a web browser is
and you're free you've paid your debt to
society you come out and they assign you
a case worker who's like all right uh
i'm going to help you out and you're
like well how do i get an apartment and
they're like oh you can find them online
they're like online what line
um no this is real this actually happens
people are going you know what what is
all this stuff and they cannot take part
in anything how do you get an email
address if you can't prove that you know
you've got a phone number or something
to use to verify it it's this almost
impossible bootstrapping process now one
initiative that i i heard about i gave
this talk uh like i said a little while
ago and someone said afterwards do you
know that there's now this thing where
if you go to the library in some
countries they'll give you an email
address and like the fact that the
librarian has met you and had a
conversation with you is considered
sufficient validation i think that's
beautiful
like you know that's exactly the kind of
thing we should have in every single
neighborhood there's a place where you
can go and go i don't have a credit card
i don't have a mobile phone but look i'm
a real person see do the internet stuff
and they're like all right we'll help
you get that set up i think that's
absolutely brilliant but you know for so
many of us
it boils down to
are you a robot no
i'm not a robot click i'm not a robot
click i'm not a robot click and the
problem is that accounts are worth money
um do any of you use a thing called get
kraken which is uh like a visual yeah um
i love get kraken it's fantastic and
when they launched get kraken in 2016 uh
they had a competition and they had a
they had like a cartoon like an
animation competition they had a
songwriting competition and what they
said to her owners the person who gets
the most social media engagement will
win five thousand dollars cash
and so you go online and you're like how
many twitter likes can i get for five
thousand actually that's a lot
um by the time they shut down their
competition the top three entries were
all people who had about 15 000 likes on
twitter all of which were little eggs
with an account like bob one two three
four five six seven eight nine because
you know if someone's saying we'll give
you five thousand bucks for the most
twitter likes and you can buy 250 likes
for 7.99 uh this is real this is insta
followers i took this screenshot a
couple of weeks ago um you know you can
go on and you can just go yeah give me
500 likes i don't care you know i'm just
out here trying to win money and if it's
a pure the person with the most likes
get the most money then this just
becomes a really simple business
transaction
but then you get into talking about the
idea of social media engagement and
promotion and getting people to pay
attention to news stories anyone heard
of the denver guardian
the denver guardian does not exist the
denver guardian was a fake website set
up pretending to be the website of a
newspaper that never existed which
spread this story about an fbi agent who
never existed suspected in the hillary
clinton email leaks um this was shared
on social media something like half a
million times mostly by accounts that
didn't exist in the first place but then
those got picked up and they got
retweeted and this ended up getting
millions and millions of page
impressions being seen by over 15
million people online and this idea you
know using the idea of false identity to
create engagement to manipulate people's
perception of what's going on in the
media this is becoming a really really
big problem now when i was a kid you
know playing around on my amstrad the
media the news came from newspapers and
tv and the newspapers and the tv they
were run by companies and if they said
something that wasn't true you could sue
them and they could go to jail because
that was an editorial position you could
say you said something that wasn't true
they could be taken to court there was a
very very kind of strict controls and
liability around libel slander
publishing copyright all these kinds of
things
that kind of doesn't really exist
anymore now there was a little point in
the the 90s early 2000s where it
seriously looked like internet providers
might be subject to the same rules as
that like you know imagine you said
something on facebook about me that i
didn't like i could sue facebook i could
be like you published something uh it
says here that uh scott helm said this
nasty thing about me mark zuckerberg i'm
suing you for 100 billion dollars and
you know i'd lose but they'd still have
to answer the case
and you know this kind of went backwards
and forwards for a little while now it's
kind of nice to think that you might
have been able to sue mark zuckerberg
because you didn't like selling on
facebook but you know imagine you could
sue github because you didn't like
something a comment that someone wrote
in a code base any kind of social media
would be impossible if internet
providers and websites were liable for
user generated content and so the
pendulum swung the other way and they
are carriers you cannot sue a website
because one of their users posted
something nasty any more than you can
sue the postal service because someone
sent you a nasty letter it just that
that legal precedent was never
established and that's probably a good
thing but you know when it comes to
interacting with somebody or something
online and trying to decide if they're
legitimate
to me it boils down to three questions
you know uh how confident am i that this
is really this person
do i trust them
and what happens if i'm wrong now the
first two of those questions we can plot
as a set of axes like this
is this really them and do we trust this
person and our top left quadrant here is
me having a zoom conversation with my
mum now yes i trust my mum she did once
lie to me about the dog going to live on
a farm but apart from that i think she's
a pretty trustworthy individual
and i know it's really her because i can
see her and i can hear her and you know
there are all sorts of cues in that
real-time face-to-face video interaction
that make me believe that this is
legitimate
the bottom quadrant
do we trust this is angela angelo was
one of my school friends who you know
you never see for 15 years and then they
pop up as a friend request on facebook
one day and uh this is angela's profile
with the whole friends don't let friends
drink prosecco and she posts pictures of
things her kids have done at school and
uh you know i go on facebook one day and
i get a hey notifications angela tagged
me and 29 others in a post that's
interesting i wonder what the post is oh
look
angela's given up homeopathy and gone
into the cheap ray-ban sunglasses
business clearly um
do you think this is really angela
yeah
no
it's i know who she is and you know i i
trust her in so far as you have to trust
people to be on facebook with them but
i'm pretty confident that this is not
angela posting this content right now
because this is a really common scam to
get people to buy i don't know cheap
sunglasses have never bought sunglasses
from one of these
like somewhere someone must have bought
some otherwise they'd have stopped doing
it and they're still doing it
so someone somewhere is buying all the
cheap ray-ban sunglasses from facebook
top right corner is it really them do we
trust them
the prime minister of the united kingdom
is it really them yes they have a blue
tick do i trust them no not in a million
years they've been fired from three jobs
for lying if nothing else and so i know
that this is this person i trust that
everything on that feed is genuinely
being put there by well face it somebody
from the prime minister's press office
but that does not mean i am going to
believe any of it for one fraction of
one second and then the bottom right
uh this is this is helen helen's a widow
with a daughter and a hey handsome
helen's looking for a special man um
is it really her i don't care do i trust
her i don't care you know at this point
and what if i'm wrong i don't care and
so that's the third question you know
what if you're wrong about it if angela
really is selling cheap ray-ban
sunglasses yeah i might miss out on
cheap rayman sunglasses uh if the prime
minister is telling the truth then well
i don't know that's just without
precedent um but if the person i'm
talking to one zoom claiming to be my
mum isn't actually my mum that could get
me into you know all kinds of difficulty
and so those are the three questions do
i trust them is it definitely them what
are the consequences if i am wrong now
it is becoming we've looked at how you
can fake someone's identity by taking
over their email account how you can
take over someone's phone number all
these different ways of interacting with
somebody facebook social media
what about video you know there was this
this famous case a couple of months ago
where somebody joined an online court
hearing um
and
for whatever reason they were a cat
probably because they'd signed the
corporate contract that said you will
not allow any unauthorized person to
have access and then they'd let their
kids play on the laptop because as
everyone knows when you sign a corporate
information security policy for the
district court of the united states your
kids are exempt from the unauthorized
persons thing because it's just too much
effort to fight your kids and so they go
on there they and you know this lawyer
is like can we do this i'm actually here
i promise you i'm not a cat and it's
like well that's exactly what a cat
would say if they were trying to
infiltrate the court system right but
video plug-ins are getting freakishly
good um i have a thing called snap
camera that i was using when we were
doing kind of zoom parties and social
stuff and uh i was playing around with
snap camera one night and some friends
joined the call and they didn't know it
was a plug-in they thought i had dyed my
hair purple because it works in real
time and it's that convincing now there
is one kind of really interesting edge
case in all this uh nvidia at the moment
they are working on a system called uh
what's the name of this thing it's uh
maxine
and maxine is a brilliant idea the idea
is you know most uh video conferencing
technology is based on the idea that you
take a video of someone's face so you've
got a grid of pixels and then you
compress that as much as you can but
you're still compressing video you
squeeze it down the wire and at the
other end you decompress it and you hope
that works what nvidia are doing is
they're like well we can do real-time
video capture and we can do real-time uh
kind of you know kinetic or cinematic
rendering on the other end and so the
way that maxine works is it looks at how
you're moving your face and it turns
that motion capture data into and we're
talking tiny you know we're talking
kilobits of data you can run full high
definition video conferencing over
dial-up internet with this thing because
on one end we have a video processor
that is literally like how far did you
move your mouth did you raise your eyes
did you do that with your eyebrows did
you move that turns that into um
telemetry sends it over the wire and on
the other end it has a 3d simulation of
your face that replicates those
movements exactly and it can do stuff
like tilt the face a little bit so it
looks like you're making eye contact
instead of looking up at the webcam
which i think is brilliant but then you
think you know what happens
if you manage to hack into someone's rig
and you steal a copy of their maxine
avatar
and now you can have a 3d replica face
on the other end um you know you're like
well i decided that i want to be brad
pitt on this call so i'm going to steal
some telemetry data from that or i'm
going to set up a head now the
interesting thing about this this is
something i've been doing a whole sort
of bunch of work and research around
faking video
it turns out is
kind of easy and within a year it's
going to be trivial
faking voices is almost impossible
because you cannot do it in real time
because until somebody has finished
saying the sentence they are saying you
don't have enough information to know
how somebody else would have said it
and so the only way that this is going
to work is if the fraudsters can also do
voice impressions
so that's what we're going to look at
for anybody who's investing in computer
learning hardware and they're going to
act in classes to do a whole bunch of
different accents that person is
probably going to try and steal all of
your nfts next year so keep a very very
close eye on them but
you know the fundamental problem with
all this kind of stuff you know trust
and security and identity
is that it all turns computers into
things that are just a pain in the ass
and they are not fun and they don't do
anything useful because what we want to
do is we want to you know unlock it with
a fingerprint connect it to the wi-fi
share the stuff we've got and yay we can
all connect and we can have video calls
and we can have happy lives and it is
kind of frightening looking at the
number of ways that all this stuff can
go wrong and it is important for all of
us you know who work in this industry to
be aware of these kinds of things to be
aware you know both as individuals and
citizens but also as developers and
administrators and product owners what
are the vulnerabilities how do these
things go wrong what are the
exploitation angles we're looking at now
coming along to an event like this and
giving up you know your own time in the
evening to listen to people like me
talking about this kind of stuff that is
a really good start you are all awesome
and you rock because you are here and
that is cool and thank you very much
everyone for coming but i want to leave
you with a quote from a guy who uh he
did one of the keynotes at ndc the first
time i was here in 2015 in oslo um it's
james mickens we tried to get him back
but he's now an emeritus professor
emeritus professor of computer science
at the university of harvard and is
therefore a little bit busy to come over
to norway and do conferences like this
but you know he had this fantastic paper
he's talking about the state of the art
and info security a few years ago and he
said you know i will not live my life in
fear because someone named freakus
maximus at defcon 2014 showed that you
can introduce induced peanut allergies
at a distance using an sms message and a
lock of your victim's hair if that's how
it is i accept it and i move on thinking
about security is like thinking about
where to ride your motorcycle the safe
places are not fun and the fun places
are not safe
i will ride wherever my spirit takes me
thank you
[Applause]
all right how we for time do we have uh
i think we probably have time for for
one question so make it a good
one oh we have no questions because
we've achieved complete enlightenment
it's brilliant
all right well i'm sticking around all
week uh i'll be at ndc for the whole of
the next three days i'll be coming along
to geekbears later so if anyone does
want to chat about any other stuff
please come and find me thank you
everyone for coming i'm going to get out
of the way and hand you over to a panel
of people who actually know stuff about
security as opposed to just googling and
telling stories about what they found so
thank you very much
all right
so uh just a quick uh quick info first
for those of you who don't know what
oasp is uh you can find some information
about us online uh
we are a
global nonprofit organization
which and here in norway we mainly do
meetups
today we're doing a panel together with
ndc and we've been lucky to get to
borrow some of the speakers which is
great
so we'll do uh a bit of uh
questions uh you can also ask uh
your own questions but we'll start with
some
some uh
some some that we created up front and
then we'll get to that but first we'll
do a quick introduction of the panel so
we'll start with patricia just uh who
are you and why do you work
on security stuff
okay so my name is patricia os i work at
turtlesec i do um i'm a c plus plus
programmer i work on native application
security and um and i do some trainings
in that area and
help clients yeah
next please hey okay i'm scott i'm a
security researcher founded a couple of
security companies just finished two
days of workshops i do
security training and a speaker as well
all right so i'm marit
uh marty tuckler i work at suprostera as
a consultant so i work a little bit with
the clients
uh preaching security there trying to
make them write more secure code but i
also work a little bit internally to try
to make us write more secure systems at
the clients
yeah
all right my name is christian i
currently work on google's threat
analysis group
and so i do threat intel stuff and
previously i've done vulnerability
research reverse engineering uh malware
analysis and so on
excellent um i'll what we'll do now is
we'll we'll ask some questions and if
you want to answer you can you can you
can also pass if you don't want to
answer them
so the first question is what do you
consider the biggest concern for
security at the moment
this is this is why i tried not to be at
the end
you have to start the tone
oh okay so what is what is
wow that's a very big question i'll
leave that to you
so it's such a big field like that's
probably the hardship announcing right
like
i think for me i specialize in crypto
and app security so in that space just
finding
i find so often that we have amazing
security features and things that you
can do very easily but often people
don't know about them i just spent two
days doing workshops and it's like hey
who's ever heard of this thing and it's
like tumbleweed and it's really easy to
turn on and it's really easy to do
and the security industry builds things
to help with security and then we have
developers and then there's like no
conduit in the middle for the security
people to talk to the developers which
is why i do a lot of training in public
speaking because
often you know we berate users or
developers as security people like it's
a common thing and i'm like often people
just don't know the security button is
there right it's not that people don't
want to do security they just don't know
like how or where or why so i think we
need to
like share information better we need to
get the information and knowledge out
there
i want to add on that actually because
usually what i say is the biggest
biggest issue in secure development is
that we don't have enough people
uh
knowing security so we have a
huge lack in secure
security knowledge
you pass okay um
and then as a follow-up question which
uh got kind of answered already but i'll
leave it for the rest of you as well why
is a lot of software still so insecure
stack overflow
sorry
i i also think that we under like
underestimate how complex uh things are
and how interconnected things are and it
is it's practically impossible to have
an a a complete view of even the
software project that you are currently
in
uh you probably only know a fraction of
it so so the complexity of it all i
think will make it
hard to to to to at at any point be
confident that it is secure for some
value of secure
and i think
again to follow the
like and not you know like nothing is
secure right like i think people kind of
chase this idea that we can have a
secure application or write some secure
code and
we never can we can only build something
that's secure enough right like we have
to recognize that it's not
security is not an absolute state that
we can achieve we just need to get to a
point where it's good enough
to do the thing that we need without
completely failing us or being hacked or
leaking all of our data on an open port
like dylan said
so it's not an absolute state it's just
a good enough state and i think most
people think it's impossible because
they think like absolute security is
this achievable thing and it's not
anything to add
nope
right
what's one recommendation you would give
to a development team
oh can i start
i i've been working on this thing uh
which probably most of you are like oh
god
is he really going to say this but i've
been working on something
i call
or
in my project we have another name for
it but it's the mozilla's a framework
called rapid risk assessment which i
used to call a
fun way to do risk analysis and
threat analysis
so
that's something i want to try to make
more developers look at try to make some
easy way to think more about security to
make it
an early part of the development process
like
think about before you start developing
right
um yeah so that's my
uh
tip to you guys take a look at that
there's a hand
should we answer that or
sure
bit louder sorry
all right so if i'm going to repeat that
so um this person said that um he is
when his team is filling out the risk
analysis they have like this huge excel
form i would like to add boring as well
can i yeah
um and that's exactly what we try to
eliminate in this rapid risk assessment
it's supposed to be short you're
supposed to focus on what data is
flowing in the system and not focus on
how um
uh what's the english word again uh
what's the consequence and how likely is
it to happen but what we're focusing on
is
what is important for this system for us
as developers to
uh
make it more secure so it's more like a
developer way of thinking of risk
analysis
but then again often if there are
projects where you have
risk managers that would be just input
to their large and
boring risk analysis right but it's a
way to make the developers think more
about what we can
do in the fun way not the boring way
yeah i think something along the same
lines
there with a rapid risk assessment is
just
uh what's the term called like shifting
left on security to make it like a
a part of the i don't know early stages
of development is probably a good idea
like if you try to sprinkle security on
top in like you know 10 days before
release you're probably gonna have a bad
time
so
yeah at least i mean even like on my
team we see like sophisticated attacks
against very
um
very mature and you know
very big projects that have
um
yeah even that have a lot of like
thought into security and even they get
like breached sometimes so uh i think
it's uh it's worth to
you know put some focus on that early on
and eliminate the low-hanging fruits
right yeah
so just how much security expertise can
we reasonably expect the average
software developer to have and is there
a discrepancy between expectation and
reality here
i think
that
as security professionals as a security
professional like we're passionate about
security and we think that everyone
should care about security as much as we
do and in reality like no one no one
cares about the thing that you care
about as much as you do right and i
think that we sometimes lack that
realization and think that everyone
should care about security as much as we
do one of the examples that i gave in my
workshop yesterday was
like health and safety in the workplace
which is a really big annoying thing in
england and i'm sure everywhere else and
they come in and they do their
assessments and
like i'm not a health and safety expert
but i know how to conduct myself in a
reasonably safe way and not do bad
things that hurt myself or other people
and i think we just need to get to that
same level with security where we have
that really small amount of knowledge
that actually fixes like 90 of the
problem
so i think
i don't think and don't want other
people to become security experts
necessarily like we just have to
identify that there's a really small
part of this that
that should be enough right like we know
enough to do
things in a safe way and not hurt
ourselves later
um i also want to comment on that okay
at university we had a professor who
said that
i'm trying to
i always fail at saying this but uh he
said something like you wouldn't educate
an uh building engineer do you say that
without um giving them knowledge about
the fire safety right yes and
he used that
as an
analogy yeah thank you uh
into security like
do we really want to educate a lot of
engineers or developers without giving
them at least a base knowledge of
security and that's the point right like
it's small
we don't need or want people
and this is another thing i think
security pros like i do we do as
security people is we expect everyone to
care about it as much as we do to know
and and in reality i hope that we don't
because we're never going to make
everyone a security professional it's
that's like a futile effort
so one one thing that i i tend to focus
on in my trainings is that
vulnerabilities are also bugs right
and a lot of the tools that you can use
to find vulnerabilities you can also use
to find like what you would normally
consider just bugs
that might not be reachable from the
outside might not be exploited by
anybody but are still bugs in our
quality issues
and so if we can use like tools to find
uh vulnerabilities uh as tools to just
find bugs then they integrate really
well into the development process and a
lot of things can be found that way
some things are are you know
just good practice and how you do things
but but i also think that it that's we
are in a field that is that we have to
learn continuously right so so if
somebody taught you about some security
stuff like 10 years ago
that's not going to be uh necessarily
what you're going to need today right so
so i i don't think it's enough to just
say you know we should have some
security stuff at university
we have to kind of realize that we're in
an interconnected
uh world like we are we are all creating
software that is somehow online or at
least reachable
and and and that we have to have at
least some awareness and and and
continuously educate ourselves
but that doesn't
you know everybody can't be an expert in
everything right
so um yeah it's difficult
yeah one thing that i think about in
like with this uh question is
if you like if we provide you know the
normal
developers with good tooling good
libraries uh they probably like
if we never made string copy right as a
function we would probably you know
there would probably be you know have
the amount of buffer overflows or
something like that just you know
providing developers with good apis good
libraries
that makes it maybe not impossible but
at least harder to you know shoot
yourself in the foot that's uh yeah
something that at least i think is
important
so i'm gonna
take one question from the audience that
i accidentally clicked publish on that
it was a good question so what's the
biggest failure you did in regards to
security why did you do it and what did
you learn from it
is someone brave enough to answer this
which one to talk about
[Laughter]
i mean like i'm a human being like i've
got halfway through a spam email and
click the link and like and you know i'm
like drinking my coffee and walking out
to the car and i'm like oh hang on
like you know this is bad
but
you know like i've found like passwords
from accounts that have been dumped and
sent to me thanks to troy from services
that i had many years ago and have
forgotten about and they're just like
the most terrible passwords before i
became a security person and use a
password manager and you know some like
derelict account like i do things all
the time you know nothing
touchwood like nothing that i know about
is bad yet because like of course i
could have been totally hacked like
dylan said and i just don't know about
it yet massage is in all of my stuff but
you know
like things happen and i think we have
like a very transparent approach one of
my companies we publish our penetration
test reports and issues that we have i
think it's more important that we're
transparent and fast in resolving things
than not having the things happen
i'm trying to think like that like i
actually did uh something like really
terribly wrong i i i did have a minister
of norway saying that i was a threat to
national security
so so wait and call over i i have to say
that was that was special
afterwards the norwegian uh um
secretary
i don't even know what that would be in
english i went out and said that i was
not so that was also nice
and then the national security agency
invited me to hold the talk for them so
i think i'm good
so
um
but yeah no i i've mostly been fixing uh
security vulnerabilities not so much
making them though i'm you know not that
i know of at least
yeah i guess for me it's like um when
i'm analyzing malware i've been you know
copy pasting urls and eyepiece and maybe
not being too careful so i think i'm not
in the same box
so yeah that's happened a few times
i think for me it's uh clicking a link
yeah yeah yeah phishing but what else do
you do with the link right like
everyone's like you should click the
links and i'm like oh these multiple i
was still thinking like a company uh
october security thingy so it wasn't
that bad but uh
i was a little embarrassed either way
i'll actually answer this one myself as
well
because the first website i built when i
went to university was a php website and
then php you had a lot of wonderful
features and one of them was what's
called the remote file include
and i i was using this feature as a part
of the website not
dragging things in remotely but like
okay now i'm going to display the frame
and i'm going to have like this page
inside here so i'm going to like show
the about page and that was a part of
the uri but you could just enter a url
there and we'll actually bring it in and
render it as php so basically remote
code execution so that was a bit
embarrassing but that was before i even
knew anything about security
so yeah things happen uh to all of us i
guess
um here's a
web hacking question
marquee
[Laughter]
yeah i've never heard about any of them
except alert so i guess i'll learn
my key tags they're the original yeah
like just scroll scrolls yeah yeah oh
yeah yes yes
you get your profile name and rapidly
you can feel young now yeah definitely
oh no this is something i heard from a
friend i definitely haven't ever seen a
marquee let me tell you about the blink
tag
old school gifts like when the gifts
were actually gifts yeah there's um
there was a whole generation of internet
that was a joy to behold
[Laughter]
how does that work
feel like a faster scroll
oh
wow
it's gonna add a whole new level to my
workshop
the web would be a terrible place
tomorrow
all right um next question uh how do we
fix the supply chain oh this is a
difficult one
wow
i mean like if i could answer that we'd
be having a zoom call from my yacht
[Laughter]
for me like the supply chain means the
javascript supply chain i work in web
app world so
you know third-party js dependencies
just
like ah we we have the solutions content
security policy some resource integrity
but they're hard to do i like one of the
solutions is to just
self-host like if you look at most of my
web apps i just pull the third-party
resources in now because we used to pull
all of these external dependencies
because it's like oh cdn and bandwidth
is expensive and shared caching on the
client which is dead and bandwidth is
now free so
you know for
pretty much free like for the most part
now i just self-host a lot of assets but
if you still want to have external
dependencies again like cspsri i talk
about these things and people like
what's this and i'm like ah you know the
solution is here now it's just no one
knows about it because we didn't tell
anyone so
you know we do have the ability to like
within my limited kind of you know
sliver of security to solve the
javascript supply chain problems
but it's just getting the knowledge out
there and making it accessible
yeah native applications we kind of uh
we're kind of behind and so we have uh
uh we we haven't gotten to some of the
problems that are in javascript but we
have the problems we used to have uh so
so um a lot of
companies that work in the native
application space they they basically um
self-host
ah but uh but they do that through the
wonderful thing of never upgrading their
dependencies so
i think everybody so you know you have
supply chain and then you have known
vulnerabilities and you can just kind of
pick which one you would like um
so
it's yeah it's a it's it's a it's an
issue you have to be on top of where
you're getting the code that you're
using but you also have to be on top of
uh
of the quality and the state of that and
that changes over time like something
that was that had no known
vulnerabilities last year for this
specific version now suddenly has one
and and how do you do that monitoring
and and
within native applications that is still
um
not a fully solved problem uh
but a lot of people are working on it
yeah i don't have an uh
a good answer but at least in the teams
i worked in we tried to make it more
like in your face to the teams that you
have dependencies you need to upgrade or
whatever but then
i also noticed that some teams take it
seriously while some teams just ignore
the whole thing so it's really hard it's
a
tough one to solve
there's there's an additional problem
for anyone who's like shipping an actual
physical product or or like
a thing that somebody will take and put
in their house or you know submarine or
or some place
oh yeah
oh yeah i've made stuff that goes into
submarines um but but how are you going
to to upgrade this thing so i'll say
it's like so yeah let's say that you
were on top of everything and and now
you ship the version to this this
customer four years ago and suddenly one
of your dependencies has like a gaping
hole in it and it's built into this
product which is in the submarine so how
are you going to do the upgrade so that
becomes a whole thing it's not like a
web server where you can just like roll
up a new new version suddenly you have
to think about how you're going to do
your
deploy to to existing customers and and
you know and
okay so submarine those people you know
you could probably call them and you
could probably set something up but you
know if if it's inside of a toy
instead of millions of kids rooms how
are you going to do like your remote uh
upgrade of all of the toys right so
[Laughter]
all right um are we safe now that we've
integrated security into our ci cd
pipeline
kind of a follow-up question
no
i have a second lap
[Laughter]
a lot of people think that security
secure coding is a lot about automation
but i would say that it's not only
automation it's a lot more
so it doesn't really help just using
automated ci cd
and tools there's a lot more around it
and even if you have
you know security testing in
ci cd and a penetration test and
you know some other things there's
like you know all of those tools on the
test for the things that we know about
like patricia said tomorrow there could
be a new vulnerability that no one
previously knew about so
nothing is ever fully secure it's just
have we
met the bar of you know basically like i
just want my house to be more secure
than my neighbor's house and then
they'll go breaking there and not me
right like so all you actually need to
do is be like one percent better than
everybody else and technically you're
unhackable because they'll just leave
you alone
so it's about just getting to a point
where
we're secure enough that we're not a
good target and someone else is a good
target instead
so having the biggest bike lock
basically yeah for sure it's like oh
well that one looks tough so we'll take
his
thanks
so we have an excellent question from
the audience here
what's up there right um
[Music]
how do you determine how much security
is enough
all of it
i'm sorry
i think it goes a little bit to what
dylan said also it's like
what are you protecting and how
important is it uh you know it's a
you don't have to have like
you know
national security level things if it's
just you know uh the name of your kids
pet
so you have to kind of decide and you
have to scale it to to to to that as
well and how much you can invest in it
because
uh you security is basically like like a
whole you could pour never-ending money
into if you want to so so there there is
a cost benefit uh to it as well
so it's a difficult question to answer i
i think
like all all questions in tech the
answer is it depends right yeah
the phrase like the official industry
phrase is threat modeling right like you
need to do the threat model and look at
what are our you know what realistic
threats do we face how much resource do
they have and how much resource do we
need to spend because it all comes back
to money in order to mitigate the threat
so
and like patricia said it depends on
what it is right if i'm a bank my budget
is going to be larger and my threats are
larger and
it helps sometimes to look at security
is kind of like an insurance policy you
know it's like the thing that you really
should have what you never want to use
but you need to have it in case the bad
thing happens and your time comes up so
you can spend minimal amounts on an
insurance policy that will get you the
minimum level of protection or you can
spend really big and get all the
optional lectures and
if you ever need it hopefully it's going
to provide better for you so it's yeah
like you have to do the threat model and
decide based on your particular needs
i totally agree with what you say i also
want to add that um
compliance actually comes in handy when
it comes to security and like all of
these regulations and laws and
everything
i know a lot of
projects where they wouldn't even do
much security if they didn't have the
these laws and regulations so we should
be quite happy for having all of this
that's also at least they have a
baseline of what should be enough
security
so we could invest in people we could
buy a lot of tools we could add all
these processes and gain all this
competency or we could just buy cyber
insurance
like you're not wrong it's like that's
the problem right i'm trying to figure
out how to backpedal out of the pressure
yeah unfortunately
we kind of see see the result of that uh
right uh the the incentives are clearly
not necessarily going in the direction
we want to but but you have to see this
as a
on the industry as a whole like if
right now we're seeing people hacking
into insurance companies to figure out
who is insured because those people are
the people you want to ransom because
they will pay you um
so so then it's like uh um
it's it's it's a difficult question to
as an industry i don't think cyber
insurance is doing us any favors i think
it's actually making ransomware to be a
good business model
but
but there's a difference between seeing
the industry as a whole and seeing it as
a as an individual company and for your
company that might make sense uh so
yeah i guess i ended up and it depends
again sorry
but you're not wrong though right like i
hate the idea of it but my company has
it because it's required when we onboard
new customers and you know in that
47-page excel document when it says i
don't use aol instant messenger i must
also have like a 1 million cyber
insurance policy
so
like i have cyber insurance
[Laughter]
you know i'm in the hole and i can't dig
out
let's do another question from the
audience
what's the worst funnest security
fuck-up you encounter it
i need a minute
i had a funny one when i was at opera i
think i can talk about it now because it
was like 15 years ago so nobody cares um
and it was in flash and nobody uses
flash anymore so it's fine uh but but i
ended up having a reported a bug where
where there was this game
uh where
where i think it was actually reported
as a bug that if somebody
used like the arrow keys in another
window uh that the the the the character
in the game moved
uh even though that the browser window
didn't have focus and and this was
reported as a bug and you know was
escalated as a bug and i
arrived at my desk and i go oh yeah we
can write a key logger and flash
[Laughter]
which i then did of course um
and it took it took literally like
i think it took like six months of of of
of
of uh bug fixing because also
it had an interaction between the
browser and flash so i basically had to
have like video conferencing meetings
with people at micromedia
but but
but yeah it was um
it was embarrassing on all parts the
only thing i could say it wasn't only my
fault so
it was it was a combined effort
but
yeah that was that was that was fun
there's so many i don't i just
like my car that could be controlled
remotely with an api token and the api
token was the chassis number which is
written in the window of every car
um
you know like i once booked a holiday
and saw the
you know the booking id number and i was
like that looks suspiciously like a
really small integer and i was like i
wonder what happens if i minus one it's
like hello john smith with his passport
details and when he's going to barbados
and
you know like that was
there's just it's so easy to make such a
simple mistake that ends up really being
bad
like
there's just countless of them you know
i took
the one that kind of got me into the
security industry
because i used to do security like
research and hacking as a hobby for
years and years and years was i found a
way to take remote control over router
provided by one of the biggest internet
suppliers in the uk and they have like
800 000 routers in people's homes and
it's like you know with a simple http
post you can take like full control of
the device by getting in his admin
and
that just turned into like a massive
news story and it's you know they didn't
fix it and then we went live with the we
finally published it and then they were
like oh now we need to fix it you know
it's like it's a bbc headline no it's a
p1
so
there's there's loads i've blogged about
them all like
have a look there's there's some bad
ones
i don't have any very funny ones i'm i
think i'm still too young
yeah but it's not really that funny but
i guess i'll uh i can tell it anyways uh
i was like randomly at the university
and a friend was like hey come over here
i need you to hack something for me and
uh it was like this scene and you were
like yeah of course
not no that would be illegal
of course yeah so
yeah so this was just like this tiny c
wrapper that would send i think it was
it would send your
code to some other through some other
program that was running as uh like um
professor privileges
at the university and of course like
when i said it's written in c already
there you can see it's probably gonna be
some bugs and uh it was pretty good like
you could pass a file name but no
special characters were allowed
uh except that they were using like
block listing instead of allow listing
so they had forgotten one character
which was the star
so when we sent in the star i mean it
doesn't really give you anything right
like you can't really make cool file
names but for some reason they had
python 3 binary
in this
directory so the star would expand to
python 3. and we would get the python 3
shell as the professor
and i was like screaming
and he was like no we have to report it
so i didn't even get to you know create
a file in his own directory
yeah so you know just a teeny tiny
mistake you forget one character and
boom you have a professor shell right
so um
funny funny security issues and then uh
we have this uh nefarious hackers uh all
over the planet doing uh
ransomware and all kinds of nasty stuff
should we start hacking back
like attack forward
patricia's just quietly crying
i just like it's such a minefield to
walk into this seems really big in
america right now i don't know if
they're just like you know yeah
shoot all the things in the cyberspace
or something
um
so
i feel like that's probably not the best
approach
you know it's like attribution though
you know it's like how do we even
you know how can you be so sure with the
attribution of where to shoot back
that you're not shooting someone that's
they're gonna hack back because you
hacked them in the first place and then
we all just end up like hacking everyone
so i don't know this is something about
that that feels really like a bad idea
for me just because the attribution game
is so unreliable you know i just
yeah
the idea worries me
yeah no i definitely i i agree on the
attribution problem and and so so if you
don't know who it is or if they just
kind of uh
you know like you saw with the with in
dylan's talk where somebody sent an
email that looked like it came from
somebody else you could do the same
thing if you get into somebody's uh
somebody's machine like grandma's
machine and then you hack somebody from
there like okay who are
the it is
like you're gonna hack around my back
it's just
just
it it's yeah it sounds like really cool
and like tv and
yeah they'll definitely be on csi cyber
yes oh yes
yeah i think one of the like biggest
problems with this is that we have a lot
of known like threat actors uh like
government-backed attackers that are
using compromised infrastructure to hack
and
well then
let's say they compromise like a
norwegian company or something and then
you ha they hack you and then you hack
them back and suddenly you know oops
i've hacked a you know legit company
it's uh i think it's uh
definitely a minefield and i guess it's
illegal as well isn't it or
yeah yeah i guess if you hack like a
real c2 they won't like sue you back but
uh
i don't know
so related to that another question from
the audience is there a particularly
interesting impressive sophisticated
attack or exploit you have encountered
you don't get to see your car again
i mean like that felt that falls short
of the impressive and sophisticated part
anyway
oh what have you got
the original xbox
where's that the save file game right
used a certain yeah name when you were
saving games and mac warrior 3 there was
a buffer overrun which would allow you
to patch the firmware on the original
xbox and install your own operating
system
but
inside a
[Laughter]
save games and job
would exploit that vulnerability and
then you could root your xbox you could
remove the drm and all that kind of
stuff um and you know that has just
that blew my mind like how did you find
it like yeah i need a copy of my career
dylan knows a lot about doing illegal
things yes yes yes
i fell into that one
um i there's like the
in about a year i'll publish a blog post
of the most sophisticated and
interesting and awesome thing i've ever
seen i'm currently working as a i work
as an expert witness in the courts in
the uk on cyber security like criminal
cases
um and in like in about a year i'll be
able to talk about literally the most
sophisticated awesome thing i've ever
worked on and seen so check back in a
year you know subscribe
[Laughter]
i think a lot of the like game console
hacking stuff is really cool uh
like what they did with like nintendo
switch for example where they found like
a buffer overflow in the nvidia like
whatever boot rom um and they were able
to like compromise uh the console and
it's you know a little bit hard to patch
because it's in the rom so they had to
do like some crazy hack to kind of to
each patch the systems and just the way
they're like recovering encryption keys
and stuff i mean i don't really
understand it but they do some hardware
trickery and then boom there's the key
it's like
yeah it's really really cool
cool um
is password guessing really hacking
i mean it depends on the context
if i have the hash locally
then no
but if i'm trying to like log in against
no yeah i guess
i'm gonna go with no
i don't think so
but like
it depends if you get if you're guessing
against like a local hash that i have
then no if i'm trying to like log into
the service and just randomly trying to
get your password then under the cma the
computer misuse act in the uk then
that's attempting to gain authorized
access so yes
but if i'm guessing a hash locally then
you know
like we'll not talk about how i obtain
the hash but i'm guessing that the hash
locally then i think that's okay
patricia's like i'm not going to
increment
let's see um
yeah more of a more of a
question for for anyone not just
developer
developers is vpn necessary for ordinary
private persons
depends on what you define as an
ordinary private person
so so so i i i think
uh i i've been speaking a lot to to or
or some to to sex workers
and and that that is a very interesting
uh threat model because they have a
totally different threat model than
normal people
or normal people they are also normal
people but people are not sex workers
and and their threat model is more
similar to to maybe people who have uh
abusive spouses that they are hiding
from so they are very uh
uh
very intent on hiding uh their their
real real-life identities um
and and their real-life locations
and and so i think a lot of cases that
where uh um
people who don't have those kinds of
threat models uh
don't wouldn't need vpns for anything
then i think uh for certain people who
are in and and
have have private identities and
locations they need to to hide
uh then then
things like vpns might make sense
on the other hand
i
i don't know how many vpns can actually
be trusted so so
this is like a massive scam world and a
lot of them are absolutely not
trustworthy in any way and you should
definitely not use them and knowing
which ones are usable and which not are
not is
is not something a lay person could do
so
yeah it's a hard question
it depends right yeah it depends i'm
just gonna give up that's uh that that's
my answer to everything it depends yeah
but like you're right though and a lot
of the time when people ask me questions
like this i can only answer with what i
do because i you know i do the thing
that i think is the most correct and the
answer is the vast majority of the time
i don't use one
so and i do you know i want to be
private online and don't want people to
see what i do and i log into secure
services and i use public wi-fi like all
for the last two days whilst i've been
training and i've not once used the vpn
so i think
with the explosion of encryption online
in the last few years
most of the
like traditional privacy concerns have
gone because the vast majority of
websites now use proper encryption and
that neutralizes most of the typical
kind of privacy threats of using a
public wi-fi network or or something
else so
there are like valid use cases for sure
but i think like a typical person in a
typical day probably does not fall into
the requirement of needing a vpn anymore
i think especially like the trusting the
provider part is probably the most
important because like okay you can
probably like hide some of your traffic
from the local network or your isp or
whatever but you're still putting you
know your trust in the provider and they
can see like at least the ips you're
connecting to and stuff so yeah so it
really comes down to like who are you
who are you afraid of here if if
if the the people you're afraid of are
not
the government or the police but the
people you're afraid of are are are
private citizens uh then then then
you're probably okay uh but if the the
moment you're saying that the people
you're afraid of are the government or
criminals or things like that
it's a little bit harder to say that a
vpn is going to help you they they might
this might be just an open uh box for
them so
it comes down to who are you afraid of
really and and i think for most people i
i don't use a vpn i i don't think that
you need one today like
like thanks to a lot of the work that
scott has done
uh you know we have uh
have http everywhere and
and and so yeah no i've yeah it yeah
sorry i'm just going to say
it depends
another question from the audience here
what do you think is the best way to
make company leaders understand they
have to put more money into security
compared to development
say i told you so about five minutes
after you get high
that's usually the fastest way that i
get budget for a project is like we
got hacked
um
but i'll think about a serious answer
now
i i usually say that don't call it
security call or something else i call
it stability and robustness and like
high up time and like branded at
something else
uh but it but it is it's it's extremely
hard to sell because how you're gonna do
that is like if you went to a customer
and you go like uh so you should give me
a million dollars and they're like why
so i can make this product that you're
using that i sold you more secure and
they're again like what what are you
saying this thing isn't secure it's like
it's an impossible thing to sell and and
the same problem is internally like how
are you going to say that sell it
internally to management it's like we
have to spend all this money to become
secure what are you saying that what you
made me is crap you know it
it's the value proposition is is
terrible as a selling point so so
selling it as something else like
robustness uptime whatever
uh quality metric uh
is easier in my experience i also often
call it quality instead yeah but um as a
consultant
uh in a consultancy company uh just
having training for the project managers
and everyone who has like a little more
to say out in the projects that's
something that i find really important
if they have the knowledge it's easier
to
um
overtole them
persuade yeah
delete understand
i think like you've kind of like tweaked
a thought there for a more serious
answer and you kind of hit the point of
not selling it as security so i know
when i do consultancy around crypto like
encryption not bitcoin um because i have
to clarify that now um you know
upgrading to the latest version of tls
right people are on tls 1.0 1.1 1.2 and
i'm like yeah come get tls 1.3 it's the
most secure version of the protocol and
they just like nod off in their chair
but it's like hey tls 1.3 is like x
percent faster because we have one less
round trip on the handshake and you know
ecdsa authentication is faster than rsa
and the page will load quicker and
then
i compare like the comparison that i
made the last time i talked about this
was
it's kind of like tesla selling
sustainable cars right it's about
sustainable transport it's about green
transport and yet you never hear them
mention
green or sustainable in their
advertising or marketing right it's like
look at this thing it's cool and fast
and everyone's like i'll buy that
and it's like haha we made you buy a
green car without talking about it and
like we need to be more like that you're
absolutely right like you know dude like
a bait and switch with something cool
but actually not you know
just sneak the security in with the cool
thing
yes i guess there was a uh i guess we'd
call it a conspiracy for some time that
that apple would release like new uh
emojis every time they had an important
yeah
that's definitely a thing
there are new emojis in this update and
like 12 critical vulnerabilities
but hey smiley dog
it works like i'm serious it works
this is an interesting one from the
audience
let's get some unpopular opinions what
is your hill to die on
there are so many hills
usability
uh
security uh vulnerabilities that are
actually usability fails
so so for example we talked about iot
one of the things is like we've had a
long time is that people have like
default passwords uh for for the device
uh and nobody changes them because when
would you do that like like normal
people they will like somebody installed
their their security system and then
there's a camera in the corner mining
bitcoin because
and and and that is that is that is a
usability fail we we missed the
opportunity to to to make someone that
choose a different password and how are
they going to remember it like if
like you talk to users and go like you
had this opportunity to change the
password and they were like yeah but i'm
never going to remember that password
now i can google it you know
it's like
so so
yeah i think i think we have issues like
that that it comes down to that that the
usability of security is is terrible
in many cases and and that makes people
do unsafe choices because those choices
are are easier
yeah so i guess it's it's a it's a it's
an unpopular hill to die on because it's
not really cool
no i mean like mine is
basically in complete agreement it's
never the user's fault like it's my hill
to down right like we it's so easy to
blame the user for things like don't
like we mentioned don't click a link
earlier and i made the joke of like oh
yes the multifunctional device that does
what else like the only thing you do
with the link is click on the link
right like there's nothing else to do
with it if i don't click on that why did
we invent it because they don't have
another purpose
and
yeah i had a consultancy game going back
months and months now and you know it's
like oh well like this was clearly
obviously like a bad link and the user
just should not have clicked on this and
i'm like well if it's so clearly and
obviously bad why don't you just write a
rule to filter it out
oh well we can't do that it's like right
so
oh it's not that obvious then is it
because if you can't write a piece of
code that filters it out then it wasn't
that obvious
so
it's just easy it's the easy way out is
to just place the burden on the user and
i i hate working on anything where
you know if the answer in the solution
involves the words the user should or
the user must this is like toss it out
the window let's sit down and figure out
how to do this properly because it's
never going to work and it's not to
criticize the user to say that they are
unreliable
like we know the user's unreliable and
we keep depending on them and then being
surprised when they fail and it's like
was it albert einstein they said like
keep doing the same thing and expecting
a different outcome is the definition of
insanity
it's like hi welcome to my job
[Laughter]
security
want to add anything
nope
all right i think it's time for the last
and most important question of all
what is the best hacker movie of all
times
war games war games okay i'm gonna i'm
just old school here it's like we're
getting good
yes
yeah oh i don't know if i can beat that
now i mean i'm kind of like half torn
between hackers and
the matrix
like i think i'm i'm slightly more
leaning on the matrix i think i'll go
with the matrix
okay
i'll go with hackers then
at the planet
do i have to choose another movie now
you can choose one of them so you're the
deciding vote now
yeah
yeah i was going to say the same thing
as patricia like i'm old school and then
go with hackers
[Laughter]
not old enough
all right i think that's uh what we have
time for today so thank you so much for
for uh
answering the questions and give them a
hand
[Applause]
and that's the right
you